you see Chris and Moses Andy I do there
they are they're right in front of me
it's like I can touch them yeah they're
on the rooftop right now and I think
there they are yes yes yeah it's
beautiful
what a sad scent we build for them yeah
yeah it looks yeah it's a rejected
outhouse from Jurassic Park yeah here as
always comic-con is incredibly crowded
isn't it amazing it is so crowded here's
how crowded comic-con is I had to wait
in line for three hours just to host
this show cuz I'm just waiting
how did it feel is my question
Luke when you bound three with your body
he cut off my hand I sure would like you
to use those I feel statements I feel
bad I feel sad I feel I feel like
flipping you off right now okay
could have been more effect I don't know
why you didn't use the the good hand
[Applause]
but there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get there right
away you gave it a little too much let's
take it back just say this bank robbery
we get there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get there
still not satisfy but okay I'll get back
geez hold on there's nowhere for this
foot to go shut the door
this isn't really instill fear does it
who sits in this this is like the Kevin
Hart mobile
[Applause]
you